well ooh a bulge it's like she's like
what's the name rule don't book with
Miss Prince who this demilitarize the
book chick if you haven't already good
book though where's the book we're gonna
find that book you can actually find
that directly linked through with social
media and Facebook page
yeah yeah he has a link on there he has
the all authorized biography of Katt
Williams
yeah the present the book down medium
thing here's a hit on himself like
deeper thought I'll do the hair on him
after the book well the thing was he
showed up and they had plastic all
rolled out like they're gonna beat him
down she's seen too many movies
you're gonna kill you there's a video
out there buddy oh yeah this is fake or
real
chopping the guy up oh my god oh my god
guy named Alex Mendoza or whatever name
I like somebody from Facebook always
send me gory photo from all over the
world but he sent me one of this guy
getting tortured by cartels the
different cartel thing is and this guy
first one they take him out of the trunk
he cut his ears off he has no ears and
he's tied up he's butt-naked and he goes
then like they're talking together a few
minutes for their biased
meena mrudula nada de la bosque de
aquila we were to top each temple in
bellos why are your employees we got him
here then a foot six on a knife and cut
his leg off like cuts it off I mean as a
sharp as knife cut people I don't know
what it was but he just got in there man
and cut him like they cut beef at the
butcher shop and I for scary me but he's
really mad and then they tried to cover
or Pichu puto and they [ __ ] hit the
food the leg gets cut off on the head
they never do like it took a ballsy
yeah it was horrible yeah you didn't
play the sound for me when you showed it
to me and I don't think I watched the
whole thing like you know you can't even
write down a movie huh
I'm sure you can do it [ __ ] well we
wouldn't know isn't that where the ice
is one just it's just that bad dude
supposedly the ice is one showed up
after the cartel videos on YouTube one
was inspired by the others inspired by
these guys cutting off heads that [ __ ]
started in 2008 I mean that's 11 years
ago the first one I watched was 2002
which was the Daniel Pearl beheading or
whatever that was you know and I watched
that on YouTube and that was what
something I wish I could unsee or the
first one I was I think was fake - it
was these faces of death yeah they're
real yeah the quarter that's old-school
like dude back in the do like oh uh
seventy bucks in our money in America
dude if you were in very funny bro you
go to prison and then some people would
kill you they had the one that the
terrorist that had like a belt a grenade
bailed on or something that blew up
prematurely and it was like blown in
half my phases of debt and in legless
and he's all alive he was well not now
as I said that was Lebanese stuff dude
like when that stuff when I saw one or
two turn it off so our door or Mexico
and there at least there's armed
protesters in front of him school and
everybody running out of the school and
the soldier heard marching in at the
same time and there's this dumb there
soldier gets his gun he's scared bro
rushing in there and some student coming
down he just blow his neck off bro and
then he just keep marching on bro
there's an order man even look back is
there you're right now following orders
just doing what the boss told me hey
wait goodbye my life will tell you early
and what do we have video she would take
a nap
he said no more I get home with a waste
of time
shoulda cheated hot dog what's up fool
that he was battling it nothing you know
you know we did a run for a mile from
you know LA to Salinas stop in okay bad
that's cool
did you get a chance to read Richards
book III read I listen to all of it
through audible all of it everything it
would tell you this is that your own
book inaudible not the whole thing no
well well well I I did when it was being
made and they'll send me like a chapter
Dawson right yeah yeah make that he told
me to tell you hi hell yeah is a badass
boy sock yeah yeah [ __ ] that [ __ ] in
the red vest
[Applause]
let's go Kmart mess before target yeah
one of my favorite one which waffle I
just hope everyone a aware now when he
was too fat it got it ass or the cop the
slow homie oh yeah yes nice little eggs
basically yeah yeah cuz some foods
wouldn't run they don't caught I'm like
dude screw you my parents are gonna trip
you know I wasn't even worried about the
police I just get the hell up out of
there and run run run and deal with the
repercussions if you get caught but I
was pretty good about getting away
except once they got me so well Richard
styling here he had a book on right now
up on the game right up on game apart
gaming system Bitcoin yes from Robbie
Burns was stopping stacking Bitcoin
speaking of Bitcoin and like I always
thought that Bitcoin was just a Seattle
or Portland or Denver you know all the
other GU cities but on the way home who
stopped at a gas station oh the Bitcoin
machine there yeah well a Bitcoin ATM
yeah yeah yeah I don't know hosting
money out of that bro yeah me too at
Facebook oh that's more like old school
that that's like when I first got in the
Bitcoin how we'd have to do it because I
didn't know anything about it so so I
find a Bitcoin ATM you put in like
whatever amount of money so say you got
200 bucks put 200 bucks into the Bitcoin
ATM it'll tell you how much Bitcoin
you're gonna get and then it spits you
out like a receipt with the little QR
code on it you scan it to your digital
wallet which is just a program you have
to download or app and then it stores it
right there so you could avoid the
Bitcoin ATM by just going to like
coinbase and like setting up your bank
account makes it a lot easier you know
and what is good one Bitcoin legal what
is Bitcoin bitcoins it's like a digital
currency where you can cycle trouble the
central bank it's look it's supposed to
be decentralized that's what's supposed
to make it so awesome is that like for
example if the if the US currency was to
be devalued or like how it happened to
Greece most recently their currency went
to [ __ ] right everything else went to
[ __ ] with it
well well Bitcoin doesn't follow those
same rules as any individual economy so
Greece the u.s. Mexico whoever can be
going to [ __ ] Bitcoin should stay stable
that's the idea but I think it's I think
there's a lot of it being manipulated
though because it's supposed to be
decentralized but if Bitcoin goes down
you'll see like all these other crypto
currencies crash with it and it's like
dude there's no excuse for it you know
so so a lot of fools got in the game
early you know I mean and they and they
were able to buy thousands and made it
huh yes but see if they still have that
cash and they're just you know they can
manipulate markets very easily really oh
[ __ ] yeah if you if you see like a
certain amount of sell orders built up
like say like 300 you know Bitcoin or
built up if somebody has more than that
they could intentionally crash the price
it'll it'll cause a chain reaction
because of the bots and stop losses that
are in place and it'll keep going and
whoever caused that because there's no
laws in place to stop you you wait till
it goes down the money that you sideline
you just buy back in at a lower price so
you get a little bit more Bitcoin and
that's the that's how some people
manipulate it yeah I mean but yeah it's
done I've seen it I've seen it crash for
like just no reason there like a
correlation between people use Bitcoin
and people who believe the world flat
think so think the world flat I think it
stripped out man it's like it's like
dude you know I understand like they
sell globes for a reader bro they're all
soft flats well it's like there's
certain means
that that you can tell yourself okay I
can't buy what's coming out of the
meteorite now because it's just too
one-sided coming out of the station oh
dude we already do but when people are
like the world's flat there's something
inside you got to be like dude you're
freaking true though it should be the
first words out of your mouth like for
your [ __ ] chart because the world is
flat if you threw a ball in the air it
will go the other way automatically will
just fall it's yeah you have all kinds
of like I was telling him when we have
those rights where you see like when in
the morning you see the whole you know
DJ's at the Blues dress you know unless
he's trying to get it you know more and
more people to space so any any
naysayers just you can save up some
money huh yeah yeah what's up full so
Doug you grew up in the otai area of San
Diego is that it's in South San Diego
I think it's technically within six
miles of the border who like close
enough
yeah close enough close enough we again
we would just if we went partying one of
their kids you had to go to TJ couldn't
get in the clubs up here but if you had
five bucks and TJ that was your ID yeah
yes I am 18 okay get in you know and and
it was a it was a cool it was a query I
really liked it down there you know it's
just it has its flaws like anywhere else
you know but uh but um my family we have
family that grew up in San Ysidro all
right they're like they're walking
dystrophin at McDonald's next to the
border dairy Mart Road yeah there used
to be a lot of car thefts on dairy Mart
Road because as soon as you hop the
border people park it walk it out we'll
know people would hop the border and
then steal a car from the conflicts
right there cuz we always knew don't go
steal cars from the complex yeah because
the vices Jacqueline they're too much so
it would be like a hot complex they tell
you that the homies would tell you stay
away in the complex because the by Sado
they jump they'll get it on flat not all
of them but you know I mean some of him
were known to you know the lyrics get
all the latest camera now what is it is
people coming in from another country
and map map burglars in a
Erica and then taking it back before the
visa expires like a tourist they're just
here I was in the like Northridge the
valley area bro and they used to your
peaceful no no these guys were Chilean
sea level all from Chile no she land
from Venezuela so they're from Chile and
but they would come here a tour as a
tourist and then they would hit
different neighborhoods in the valley at
different times so one guy comes for two
weeks on vacation robs a bunch of houses
and cars goes back with the goods or
sells him here and takes the money back
and nobody knows that it was him doing
it he's gone I make sense and the next
guy comes it was like five or six guys
comes no he'll go in the wrong other
neighborhood another circle you know in
the neighborhood seems there teams it's
a whole team but they'll go at different
times not to arouse suspicion and then
they finally caught him and they
realized it was all these guys just come
in as visitors every once in a while and
just robbing on their vacations and
going back and they created something
where you can intercept week so I go
this couch did you for a lifetime huh
but they were this thing or they were
using this thing that intercepted
people's car locks to intercept and
burglar alarms and they would they would
intercept it as you're setting it and so
it wouldn't really sit but your ideas
here I knew I do that with the car girls
garage door openers yeah yeah you're
sitting there all right anytime
somebody's with a little device figuring
it out oh yeah my car thief game is like
not on point I I haven't stolen Carson's
like 2002 when um when I was like living
living in the Boyle Heights and
everybody like we we live like next to
the housing projects so all the
factories were ours
you know like Goodfellas either ours
yeah and like if you guys just like if
you worked her if you got your car
stolen once your car get stolen five or
five times in the same month
my friend Chivo he would always steal
this fat man's station wagon whoo
work there like we know he knew he was I
he's a large bra and I hope take off
with a station wagon and steal it and
then dump it somewhere and then then
he'll get it back there my friend cheapo
go back three months later stealing
again because you know there's no alarm
there's no alarm and I got never they're
easy to break in you just take off
cruise to the beach come back and that's
where they left that note Louie bro
that's Louie Louie with another guy he
broke it to the burgers - it was fun and
that they closed that five and he stole
everything and then he came back the
next time before he story after him in a
fat ass burger and they left a note
I struck again a wild man you think in a
way you want to be known but you want to
give a guy message yeah
now you leave something behind like
remember this guy named the cheetah the
Conchita and this other guy named
question test and this other fool right
what anyway is that fool John Wayne or
okay whatever he wasn't even there at
the crime scene but it was these two
other dudes in another dude they broke
into my elementary school bro and I
stole a lot of stuff and then they took
a big dump on the principal's office
yeah but then they rode one other little
brothers name somewhere oh not how they
caught everybody that's kind of a theme
like that I noticed in your stories in
your book that you you tended to
surround yourself with guys who were not
as what do you call it right they
weren't the best criminals to be
alongside you you know they often
tripped you up I think I couldn't
because your brain seemed to work a lot
faster than theirs maybe I had some
friends that were pretty on point but
yeah it's I wasn't the sharpest tool in
the shed back didn't either I mean I
mean I robbed when when I did get into
robbing banks when I was 18 I robbed my
own bank once that I was doing my car
payment loan through so I had to make
all my payments after it closed every
single time after that I'd put it in
through the mail slot and then and then
I ride my own mom's Bank twice you have
your first bag of junior high
no no that would be way in at the begin
of the bully talking about you wrote a
note you gave it to the team smile yeah
yeah no no I was 18 I was a first woman
in junior high I was just doing more
petty theft stealing from the school I'd
get like suspended on purpose and they
keep me after school and I'm a cleanup
all the teachers offices but the janitor
so you learn huh well I had been
stealing since like third grade was my
first hustle third grade I used to steal
Playboy's on the way to school yeah yeah
I'd sell them s and then I'd sell them
at school and other than that it would
be like stealing food stealing clothes
but yeah I wasn't I wasn't uh again i
Ramones mom bank got away with the clean
and then I was I will would be the best
idea to go rob it again they'll never
see that coming you know and they didn't
when I walked in here's a surprise for
me was for me twice
yeah yeah I'm one of the chapter was but
I guess it was the woman guys get away
mm-hmm and in the guy said we're gonna
do and you need to cover like 600 you
guys paid 600 bucks each that was my
bank yeah and then yeah and then that
guy said when you want to do it again I
really thought right there that you're
over back and within the hour
oh I really tell you another one like my
self-esteem had been dropped too much
yeah I was questioning myself like oh
man how can I only get like 12 bucks
you're angry you know like they have the
book or the Anarchist Cookbook
oh yeah I read that in school your book
and let the like took that like the
robbery cookbook and I tried not to make
it like that that's why I tried to
breeze over the bank robbery line like
every time I thought about something on
my answer my question what answer in
your book okay I was I kind of dad oh
okay I wouldn't know it in my own
handwriting
what was the FBI files the the TV put me
up on game I remember
like the way you think you know and the
way you think is that the way I love you
but my neighborhood think like anyway
you know me you just be chilly doing
nothing yeah living straight up like a G
you know like now being like constant
problem you know you say you haven't
robbed the bank and took this robbed a
car 2002 and spent years have you done
it yeah but for some reason like April
these doors are so he's it open like
that to solving solving which is like a
little tiny German at seven yeah I could
have run this town yeah we were walking
through the little town he's like many
stores are so easy to push up and you
just walk nobody has yeah man I thought
I felt like Jack Nicholson in the Joker
wait'll they get a load of me yeah yeah
I see that too sometime when I'll go
into banks like inadvertently I'll pick
it apart in my head and be like okay so
that's where the money is this is about
and and then I'll have to shake you like
ah stop thinking like that no back then
it was because initially I did it I was
just probably fed up you know again
we're trying to scrape up money for a
grande me like that Taco Bell was like
our program we get a grande milk
two-liter a male dog our new meal two
liter and and then and then that would
kind of set us for like half the day and
we're playing Halo and we're like
alright let's get the money together you
know what I mean we started emptying out
our pockets do we have like less like
maybe six bucks you know and the
gardening mill is like seven and some
change plus the two-liter would have put
you closer to ten and and I remember
sitting there and I was just looking at
it frustrated dude and I was like
[ __ ] foolís rob a bank you know and
that that yeah and then you know you say
stupid [ __ ] when your teenager but then
my [ __ ] other stupid teenage your
friend was like oh [ __ ] it let's do it
and when you're in the neighborhood and
you speak on something and then you
don't follow through they look at you as
less than oh you're a [ __ ] you know so
he said well [ __ ] it let's do it I was
like alright [ __ ] it you know and I
started reaching for shit's cut out of
no hat glasses burglar gloves
and we already had a stolen car outside
we're waiting for some food to come
check well the system and rims I think
and then so we already had everything we
needed and and I had been watching it
been wanting to rob a bank by that point
for at least four or five years and then
finally at eighteen you know you know we
did it but but again even if he would
have said no I could have hit up any one
of the other homies and you know you
know what the [ __ ] I'm talking about you
know I mean you you call he says no if
you really want to do it you're gonna
find somebody that will whereas in a
regular everyday scenario you find that
you're hateful as well banking and the
feds are gonna show up at your pet yeah
you wrote the note which read a note
again I wrote smile at the top however
when I arrived on scene to rob the bank
I forgot I wrote that part but I wrote a
smile at the top and then I put put the
money on the counter knowing pecs and
arms tracing devices there's two more
guys outside with guns later I would say
I want both drawers cuz they have a main
cash or petty cash drawer and I and
eventually that that would be my mind
but the first one smile put the money on
the counter no impacts alarm Streisand
vices there's two more guys outside with
guns hurry up this ain't no joke and I
was in line for a minute dude I stood
behind other people cuz you know first
time robbing a bank I don't know what
the hell you do and I walked in and it
was one of the ones in the grocery store
you know I mean so it's a weird one to
choose the easy was because I was i I
was familiar we never see a guy with a
gun outside of those ones I was going to
marry you just take a particular Liam
shopping bag on yeah yeah and they give
you a year for a bullet you know I mean
so even if you use a gun the wisest
decision would be don't have bullets in
it so I got the grocery store give me
the money
it was a thorough monopoly yeah any
grocery you give me the money in a
2-liter you know I slid to her and she
smiled and and I cut it out the size of
the check so that way when I went in
people would think I'm cashing a check
you know I'm saying and and I and I slit
her right then she knew because I'm
wearing he loves freaking I look like a
straight up shoulder yeah I mean like
straight the [ __ ] up like a bank robber
cholo in line at a bank you
again not sharpest tool in [ __ ] you know
and I slid a Turin she she's separated
with her index and middle finger of the
right hand and started reading it and
and I'm nervous you know looking around
like oh god is anybody creeping up I
mean and then I look back at her and she
smiles and she's like do you got a
bagger genuine you know and she's
smiling on paper or plastic yeah yeah
but her smiling I mean like really
[ __ ] me up cuz again 18 year old
freaking guy you know nervous already
and then the hottest chick in the place
is my yes so I'm like man I should get
this chicks number you know like all
that shit's crossing my head I'm like
cuz cuz that's what you don't know you
as we normally do at the mall you see
this my hey was so gross your number you
know so I was think I should I do and I
was like nah it's a conflict and then I
dipped out but yeah on the way out of
the driveway the homie tells me show me
the money show me the money and I had a
little Carl's jr. bag that I had just
scraped up off the floorboard of the G
ride stolen car now pull the money on it
was like a grip of 50s I remember that
was a red dance and there was some fries
hanging out of his deal and we both just
started smiling you know and [ __ ] you
nobody was it the first it was close to
like eight G's if I remember maybe a
little over but but we had decided
hurtin and they're like [ __ ] you you
know when you want to do it again she
yeah yeah yeah and and well easy I I
don't know gently like blah oh yeah
heart pounding will you hear anything
else cuz I would imagine like it like in
the movies brought I would usually most
with have a soundtrack but a good movie
bro like heat there's no song shy boys
just monkied how hearts pounding people
running or you can feel the adrenaline
man I can't believe driving man it was
the homie
it was the homie he ended up on wheels
he ended up falling out of the SIRT out
of the circle pretty quick not because
you did anything wrong with us but he he
got caught with something and then on a
side note they took him to jail so he
wasn't involved anymore and we recruited
another homie but yeah it was I can't
remember exactly what the hell is theme
because in the surveillance photos since
I was in line at the
Grolsch or they had one of those stands
with like magazines you know I mean so
unbeknownst to me you know I I was just
focused on my surrounding but they had
surveillance photos where I just picked
up magazine I'm like try necktie a snake
could speak you see I mean and so I was
looking like a burn everybody was
looking at me by the time I walked up
but yeah I remember when it was my turn
next is what it was it was all coming
down to that I was next in line two
people or three people were already
being helped and then I was thinking
shot do it should I do it should I do it
you know and and then I was think it's
before seconds and I'll see a man if I
don't do it the [ __ ] home he's gonna
think I'm a [ __ ] you know this is I
shouldn't say I was gonna do it and then
she was like next you know and I was
like left out or right robbed the bank
and I just started taking a step and
went to the right into a pool you just
maintain your pool enclosure that's it
right I've always been even though it's
inside your head you're gonna [ __ ] Mike
shatter you're just like I've always
been able to hold my composure more than
you know under pretty stressful
situations especially once I got to
prison but uh yeah that was one thing
about me is I I was pretty cool
collected I'd always be quiet you know
watch observe her sunglasses yes in the
bank yep hat glasses gloves hat or
sunglasses
I had creased up flannel shirt like
react sold the way he talks about his
clothes as the way MC poncho talks about
his I mean like the creasing and the
bookstore's yeah it was definitely a
trip so you you are I'm a row how many
um you you got arrested 19 right yeah a
couple months after I turned 19 that one
time right I I never got caught
red-handed I got caught in an
investigation and then it caught me but
but yeah I got you look-alike first yeah
had after poor [ __ ]
that is like though like like most cops
are my they pressure your pressure to
you finally gave in why I came from i
recomment up in the bank before that one
screw them over huh he he put himself
yeah other cops why
is to put your your ass at the crime
scene even if you don't even if you
didn't shoot the guy even if you didn't
hurt the guy but they want you to be in
the vicinity of the crime now you could
have gone yep no they could prove it in
court it's a slippery slope
yeah I had I had when I got cracked on
the on the bank robbery thing I ran into
that fool to the stunt to this prison in
County Jail wha
and and he was in a holding tank in and
he was asking me he's like hey aren't
you Richard Stanley I'm like look you
know and I already had an undercover Ian
I know for a fact it was on your car
keys he knocked after he didn't get
anything out and they pulled him out so
I was already on guard I was already
like Oh God and then this fool walks up
like Oh weren't you rich and he starts
telling me his story and I was like oh
okay you know but uh I had found out
when he got cracked because someone was
at the trolley station they just seen
what it turned out this fool had been
there he was my height my build for the
deflection dressed the same frickin way
as me hat and he was checking some chick
out and you know what she she said he
was checking out her shirt which was a
place that she worked at or something
right I ended up finding this out later
because I did a by slant documentary so
they went in and like did some digging
okay and and and they were telling me
this fool was checking out her shirt so
she got scared and then she started
looking out and was like oh god that's
the the police had told her she had been
robbed at some point not a bank teller
and the police told her it's the skinny
bandit that robbed you so skinny benders
can you ban is what the kind of bastard
you know you're not supposed to pick on
teenagers about their weight so so I
could have caught Patrick their gear
broke the comedian I found you and
Patrick the gear I don't know you know
him
I'm not sure dude you got her dress the
same he's skinny also same height same
goatee except that he's blind
Oh same hat but he sees from this way
peripheral or if we are projecting gear
you got it you could have been come with
murder bro
number two bank robbery yeah the
prosecutors were still locked in with
all your plan yeah tell it to the judge
if Edward Norton wasn't offending oh
that area would've picked up oh yeah
who's that well that's we got rolled up
on strong you know I got caught easy bro
well you've stared of a comedy palace
survival she points out the wrong guy
long story short and then the cops roll
up take him in he doesn't know what the
hell is going on some somebody that I
knew was up the station and they're like
hey what's going on they're like that's
Andy and they're like no we meet and
they looked in there you know and they
came home to where they went to my pad
where I was staying it told me they're
like they're like dude they caught the
skinny bandit like what the [ __ ] you
talking if you think you were home free
after that for a bid I did and then I
stopped robbing banks for like a week or
two but then I was like I [ __ ] we
keep robbing him you know and it was
that one girl that identified you with
that Honda you guys told her Honda they
recognize you from school that was a
separate occasion that was how I
actually I got put into a Linux they led
to you I had a yeah I had a homie that
needed help one of my associates in the
circle was like hey this food this food
needs help you know he needs to come up
quick can you help him out can you take
him with you rob a bank I was like oh
yeah [ __ ] it you know so I told he was
right there you know kind of sitting
outside of the circle and I call him all
right foot let's go let's go get a G
right let's go steal the cart
he was a ye well I thought you had me
the cash easy investor I told him that I
said we'll go tomorrow you know but but
he wanted to steal a car from somewhere
he was comfortable with you feel me so I
went to my neighborhood which is where
we were having the conversation stole a
car I was flipping through it scene a
little freaking sticker on a visor on
the passenger side visor like ah she
looks familiar I told the homie I was
like his chick looks familiar
he's like oh she does and we didn't
think anything of it went robbed the
bank the next day and it turned out it
was the girl that I went to high school
with and [ __ ] and when the cops
showed up like yeah your car was used in
a bank robbery buddy skinny bandit and
she asked for the wanted poster so I'm
and I showed it
to her and she was like oh [ __ ] she went
into her freaking pad grabbed the high
school high school dude and she pulls it
up he's like I think it might look right
here yeah most likely
who's that Tweaker chick that like
called and asked you all those questions
out when they blasted you what was her
little rollers old lady the girl the
girl the girl I was with at the time in
the hotel room she had a friend a
Tweaker friend and so so I would she had
my number I had hers it wasn't uncommon
for her to call me
especially wasn't uncommon for her to
call me at 2:00 3:00 a.m. yeah she calls
me and she's like hey were you you know
what I'm like over here she's like who
are you with you know so-and-so you know
what roomie you named [ __ ] this room
you know are you sure there's nobody
else there I was like know why and she's
like okay bye
I'm freakin hung up and I was like
freakin Tweaker you could write oh good
bro but then I wake up to the just a few
hours later yeah did you go reward Oh to
give her a lighter there was a reward it
wasn't too much it was like a crime
stopper Janet in January they gave to
her I don't know a pod box full of magic
the way she's telling it they like
stupid cop lie to me
well he probably got it out of her a
little pickle I heard she got her kids
back is what to do with kids back
there's always a Tweaker theater kids
back here yeah you know it's only right
tweaking for my kid
so when you went up you grew up in a
Latino neighborhood and um you danced
Mexican yes he was the from apart he's
from TGA well my his dad's from dramas
yeah his dad his dad's from Durango
there's family in Guadalajara but he got
raised in a Florido
in in Tijuana it's like way out there
you know I mean but by a company called
Mattel where they make the toys and [ __ ]
but uh yeah I was ghetto no no the water
truck had to come by to fill up the
barrels no trash service you got a
Bernie I mean what was cool
one time I got banished out there for
like a period of time because I was
[ __ ] up and they sent me to my
grandma's pad and and how you burn the
trash yeah I was burning it and I threw
a [ __ ] lighter in there BAM just to
watch it you know because
pyro noise so burn my face my eyebrows
once you find up because it crack makeup
on this chola cracked and and you could
see the [ __ ] little bubbles like like
like a carbonation and I was like oh
that's cool and I moved in holding up
melted my hair right here in freaking
eyebrows and eyelashes my mom and dad
had to come over all the way over there
and get me yeah she said oh yeah grew up
in a you did your parents end up by the
house of what house the first house
right
the first house yeah that I think we are
on yeah was in was in the neighborhood
it was in a off of Melrose Avenue yeah
it was like a little rinky-dink
chain-link fence around it what would
your dad do for a living yeah he was a
driver since he was like 11 or 12 then
you talk about this one summer where you
thought you were gonna cheat you won't
get that by the first house and then
your dad pushed your dad push to the
corner and told you um all the other
other fixes the house it was only a new
roof base and you're like oh I kind of
got a lot of money
what do you mean money eh we got two
pitchforks yeah no he was I will just go
get some pickaxes the damn fence posts
take that towards that you know what
about race and the dam blamed the port
wall I didn't do the concrete poured but
I had to help homeboy that he had to
hire casino purveyors couple for the for
the rebar too good to catch the wall
like the base yeah had to dig the trench
for it basically no we had to do we had
a hill in our backyard that one of those
hard-working fools huh oh yeah you had
you could feel like how many years ago
work it out if I'm being honest when I
got cracked for he's such a hard worker
so as soon as he got his citizenship he
put the American flags on both side of
his day and he was all psyched you mean
that like he's real hard worker always
wanted me to be it when I was a kid I
remember him showing him trying to teach
me how to drive 18 wheelers and I was
already too far gone you know I mean and
I was like 14 15 and he was like yeah I
did it and then he mentioned so I was
like pull over so I use the bathroom
he's like well not right now they'll see
that we pulled over
like what do you mean they'll see that
we pulled over he's like there's GPS in
these things and I was like where can I
find I'm watching Goodfellas like - you
could get a whole truck cigarettes
really but all of it now there's GPS so
my mind was are you all criminalise dude
by the time I was really on you know but
he he if I'm being completely honest
when I got cracked for bank robbery he's
such a hard worker such a like straight
arrow that uh he he visited me one time
when I hit County John that was it I
mean he was not having the crime tell
you he did not like it why'd you do it
yeah but I I had told him one time just
I said it as a joke but I told him you
know when I went up home to visit
because they had moved to Lakewood
eventually during the bank just before
like it all right yeah yeah bigger one
better one they both got transfers and I
went up to visit and I had put a TV in
my car when that she was [ __ ] bought a
car and you put like a TVs in the rears
and you had you play like a xbox or
something I had a station yeah water
doing the hits takes a [ __ ] play Madden
well you're either a drug dealer or
celebrity 99,000 that was 2002 did you
have that joke for what he almost
[ __ ] crashed looking at the Laker
game and some - yeah yeah
I said well Jerry high some girls car he
goes almost crashed trying to look what
the Lakers on her car I watched the
whole movie the cell with Jennifer Lopez
you know driving up to Lakewood from San
Diego and then and and and I put it in
the in the in the PlayStation to watch
it and when I got there I was like dude
that movie sick I got to watch it again
cuz I know I missed some [ __ ] I watched
it again I didn't miss a [ __ ] beat I
was like damn I could've caused an
accident
I saw everything on the way we're dream
her mind the mind
I gotta watch that movie again it's good
the soundtrack is pretty good to hear
it's a beautiful movie it's very vision
shot you know the way her parade dressed
is yeah
the way her red dress is that stop spawn
his red cape was like that yeah oh the
walls start coming with them now see he
always a hustler huh yeah like you knew
like like you have a like a come up like
you know back man
my mommy just saw a vials you just saw
top of where she saw Krista promotions
she was talking sell everything back man
I was so everything two men one time I
mentioned it before I brought my mind is
badass brush and I took the brush and I
took her to school and you this guy was
cool on here yeah which to cut him the
count and I [ __ ] saw that brush to
him for six bucks no huh or eight bucks
and he took your brain over this moment
is we're like watching this brush your
mom's at home like so how many banks
totally do you hit or robbed well total
[ __ ] they say I robbed 13th was a total
count on record that you your home
everything oh oh oh I don't know the the
the the Vice that people asked me not to
and I honest you don't know it it would
kind of you know it would average out
I'd say a fair average would be eight to
ten thousand per bank you know but
sometimes you're gonna have to get
multiple tellers yeah I would I would
try and choose banks with honestly more
people working because there's just more
money available there's more drawers
that got stocked so I would always go
from one teller to because I think in a
second it might have been the first or
second time I ended up probably second
time I grew some courage and I was like
I want her drawer to and she was like I
don't have the key to that one and I was
the okay well so my solution was I have
to ask each and each other you just tell
their individual that's why you got so
good at that speech like I forgot to ask
you like how you memorize that letter
every free moment well they put the
money on the counter new lines because
you're always that's what I mean
I meant by you know you're surrounding
yourself with people who are maybe less
everyone with you on the 13 that they
say I robbed it was just me and then I
think look like in going in the bank
what are you Priya to ask for Edwin in
there a I had area the second time I
robbed my mom's bank I had somebody with
me he he never got the mother not with
you my mom was living in LA so if she
wasn't getting to see the news from San
Diego oh yeah yeah I know what I've seen
before yeah when I went up there they
asked me where you getting all this
money yeah that's all I robbed like
three four banks did you have any legit
job that they thought you were doing I
had I got a job at UPS that's how it my
mom helped me get my car and then I Cana
steai quit UPS because September 11th
happened right so I was convinced I was
going to join military you know I mean
and and and and I went to work and I
quit you know I was like I'm gone I'm
going in the military I went with the
home and you go to freaking the Marines
and they started asking us questions you
know like what do you want to do you
know I'm like no and they were asking
and then ask my friend what you want to
do and they were showing them option you
over build radio towers on the radio in
your whole life yeah I mean and so they
asked me again well like what do you
want to specialize in my own [ __ ]
specialize in the infantry food you know
like rip it has all y'all so ressure
they shut me down either cuz I didn't
pass the test cuz I'm telling y'all
stupid you know and or or because I was
too gung-ho so so he got accepted went
to the Marines I got kicked out and down
jobless and I got [ __ ] and then I got a
job at Pinkerton security and then I was
walking down the street with the homie
again shortly out two weeks after I got
shut down from the Marines and a tourist
pulls up on it and we're banged out -
yes we both have shaved heads he looks a
little more gang members than I do
but we get rolled up on by a freaking
tourist we think it's the cops
you know they pull up right in front of
us and that's usually how it happens and
then two fools hop out in uniform and
one of them was like do you want to join
the army and we look each other
and then so we hopped in the car and it
took us and again they freaking we're
like what do you want to do I was like
the infantry you know and they're like
we can't but like what else do you want
to do I was like what else is there to
doing the infantry mop I don't know [ __ ]
about there you know but I know that I'm
pissed off you know I mean cuz that's
all I knew you know I mean I was pissed
off I want to go they didn't go and then
the other guy the second time he didn't
he didn't end up going either cuz he was
I was 18 he was 17 and they just
flat-out rejected me they told him
they're like we'll help you get your
diploma if you weren't like dude I have
my GE yeah so oh oh it's just gonna ask
so you hit all you hit all these banks
and then your your whole thing was about
weighing risk and reward basically and
that's what yeah that's why you were
memorizing the speech was to maximize
your reward shot I also thought I was
being clever with I never wanted to hurt
anybody I was I I had homeboys growing
up you know and you know there's some
fools that are like more crazier than
and if you say the wrong thing the whole
you know so I wasn't really like that I
was always more mellow more like
freaking just just trying to get by you
know when when see me whenever the
homies would be hateful let's go
gangbang and I've done Oh steal a car
yeah I mean do you guys want to go with
me and I'll go make money and then I'll
start trying to make them feel like [ __ ]
like come on man you guys are gonna go
[ __ ] get beat up yeah I mean we go
over here make some money yeah I mean so
so that would be my lip so I was always
known as a thief I was never known in my
neighborhood is being like a crazy
gangbanger I was always known as the
hustler the thief you know I mean and
tell the story of how you got into the
gang cuz I thought that was really
interesting you weren't jumped in well I
had I had always known I I had always
hung hung out with the homies ever since
I was a kid but I never I never felt
that I should I was never like forced
into that position like for example you
I remember you you saying you know you
were standing there and then they if we
went and then they just cracked yeah
and that and it does it happens just
like that most the times but uh but I
mean Laurie I was at a house party after
school with with the two homies and we
were at this was Pat do you want largest
[ __ ] and maybe I was saying
yeah he was huge yeah I mean by adult
standards yeah I mean monstrous and but
he was really cool you know he had
already been to prison here but he he
didn't have that chip on his shoulder
that come with the size and the prison
he was really cool really respectful
everybody looked up to him and he was
telling me he's like he'd see me there
and then he called me over me and I mean
he was like sec - weren't you from the
neighborhood you know [ __ ] [ __ ] kill
me no and I was like thinking what's the
best thing here and I was like I'm just
not you know I don't know and he was
like yeah but why not do you know I'm
like I don't know and he told me he's
like well if your homeboy here you know
so-and-so here was to run to some [ __ ]
are you gonna run this are you gonna
lead this food behind I was like he
already knew who I hung out with my
squad and I was like they're all from
the hood more except for one and I was
like well he'll knowing you know and
he's and he named off like one or two
other homies and and I and I was like no
no and he's like we'll see if you're
gonna be in the middle of [ __ ] anyway
you may as well join the neighborhood
right and I was thinking about I was
like well [ __ ] I do get beat up a lot
for the neighborhood so I was like was
yeah you know like and then he was like
the other home he was like that's right
fool you know and it was it wasn't that
that I would not have probably ended up
getting jumped because there had been
fools in my neighborhood at that point
that were like you know already like 20
21 they hadn't been jumped in but they
were known as being those fools yeah so
no one ever really made the step
hey let's jump them in because for one
this [ __ ] has like 30 fools from
the neighborhood from his family you
want to jump me and okay cool me and my
cousin's are gonna come [ __ ] get our
hits in on you so there are certain
foods that it was just they wouldn't
[ __ ] with because it was the right place
for their me me I just got snatched up
too early probably for that to happen
you know because eventually it would
happen you're you're just hanging out on
the right set of circumstances I could
easily found myself at one of the house
party that I'm telling you I would
always gather
Squad and let's go come up you know that
was my team
yeah thousand again cuz I let everybody
run it's at my house after a crime scene
yeah I used to do that to my girlfriend
crystal I mean give me a Batman would we
hold him there no it was taking a
college for two days yeah so and when
you got convicted well what what was it
like starting to go to prison prison
like you were in County for a while we
got CBC or you know I was in San Diego
they um well for one the feds had to
step step out of the case fairly quickly
only because they had arrested the wrong
person so they turned me over to the
state from there they sent me to the
downtown San Diego jail and then from
there they transferred me over to George
Bailey which is out near old-time ASA
near the prison out there and I was
there for like probably like five months
at that County Jail so I was already
hearing the stories you know like all
yeah don't trip you know it's it's it's
not so bad the food's better the homies
got your back that but people would warn
me stay out stay out of certain things
don't get into drugs don't get in a
gambling don't get into the mix in
prison you know like the the heavy
hitter circle cuz all those three things
will wreck you you know eventually and
or so that's what they would say so when
I hit when I hit prison I wasn't too
stressed I was more worried about the
guards cuz cuz you would see the gun I
was kind of prepared for prison just
from living in my neighborhood you know
and and and I don't think you've been to
prison but if you were to just from
having grown up where you did you'd be
alright you'd recognize some of the
hustle some of the lingo and you'd be a
little better off half elope my neighbor
was in there oh yeah voted for you
unless Comic Standing for yes I was I
wish I could remember their names but
yeah I was with again I was there for
seven over seven years I was with a
bunch of fools from early but I Boyle
Heights you know but uh yeah when I got
to prison I had a lot of older I had my
friends that were my age their older
brothers that were like already like 20
21 22 they had already been sent to
prison so when I got there they were
there waiting on me you know so when I
got there there lit they pulled me over
to the yard
and then it was more like just saying hi
hey what's up I haven't seen you [ __ ]
long this is where you've been you know
but I did you automatically did you
automatically gravitate toward the
Mexicans or like was there the race
separation when you got there was it
noticeable where you not so much a lot
of people say race immediately when
they're thinking about prison and and
and it is the case in certain well not
even I would say maybe that's the case
with like the white guys but there's
even Jewish people that role with the
that have to by default role with the
wood car so it's not so much race you
could be white you could be black you
could be Cuban you could you know
Hawaiian Asian and you Armenian and you
could be from a southern Hispanic gang
now I'm not gonna deny that being
Hispanic in that case will help you you
know but ultimately it's going to come
down to where you're at what are you
willing to do what are you willing to
put on the line because whenever
something cracks and again I haven't
been there in 10 years so whenever I
speak it's not about current conditions
I don't know what the hell's going on
right now but when I was there it was if
we're all gonna jump in the right so if
I'm walking the art in to fools from a
different car come and rush me I can
count on my car to come whether they
hate me or not to come and help me
because it's it's to prove a point like
you don't [ __ ] with the car Union you
know I mean but but again yeah yeah you
could be Mexican you're from a different
car in prison and then you're going at
it with each other you know so it's it's
it's more what car you're from and where
your loyalties lie
you said that on your book that out I
don't know for the first week you were
there there were like a riot the first
week or the first we year the first week
in prison mm-hmm and you saw someone get
stabbed and you only get about you go
ahead should go help him he's vasa
it wasn't her stood back well we try to
stay back I did you know I did get in a
riot when I first got into prison but
but you're talking about the guy that
got its throat yeah yeah he was he was
Mexican I was I was I was tally on the
handball courts meaning I'm up next but
if they hit the ball and it goes
somewhere else you got a chase after you
and then you return it and then you're
up next after whoever he was so I was
talking out there you have me really
what they handball and the ball fly to
the other wall you hope
the to food renege are chasing their
ball I got a good story for every remind
me about the wall and Italian and so so
I was standing there playing Italia on
that one and then the yard goes down
like man what the hell so we're looking
around looking around then I turn around
and maybe where that light set up you
know within 10 feet this was yeah yeah
and I'm like oh god you know and he just
stumbles he starts heading to the gun
tower so the sniper could probably get
an easy shot on whoever it was that was
tripping on him and then he fell out in
the dirt and then the meat wagon came a
little tan van with no windows in the
back old like from the 70s or 80s they
throw his ass in there and then they
take him away I never seen him again but
another time I was playing tally the
first prisoner I'd ever been in was for
paisa
yeah we call him King paisa King paisa
his name was a rapper name huh his name
he was a three-strike lifer I think on
some drugs forgive I stresses but he was
cool he was really cool yeah yeah third
one's for drugs so maybe he's out now I
don't know but he did at least 20 and
for that off of like possession of meth
or something but uh but uh he was
playing freaking volleyball because this
would like to play volleyball a [ __ ]
he volleyball well the only people that
were available to play were the woods
right so this was so you could play
volleyball in other games with the wits
oh so I'm playing handball BAM I have a
killer freaky and you ball up your fists
and just bam knock it to the top brick
to send as far back as possible into the
gravel in the dirt
real hard to recover i frickin hit it
BAM just as it's flying over the frickin
corner of the top cinderblock the alarm
goes off and I'm like Oh God and then
we're looking around we don't see
anything I'm playing handball with the
homie named speedy he was from Logan
down in San Diego and I look around the
wall and it looks like there's just a
mosh pit dude of woods you know I mean
just going you know you're the [ __ ]
we're looking looking and then I was the
one who caught a glimpse of him it was
King Faisal Bethel in the middle of it
just swinging
oh yeah so I slept it EIC food's better
run we just start running into it and no
one knows what the hell's going on
that's why no one else was jumping
because you can only see wood so we work
our way to the middle still no one knows
what happens no one jumps first they
think I'm just another white guy running
into the [ __ ] mix and speedy he's
shorter than me I don't know or he got
lost in the crowd
yeah I mean once he's in there and
they're firing off the frickin block
comes brah
and eventually everybody gets down but
uh yeah I was always pissed off that my
first [ __ ] prisoner I was for
volleyball technically but but yeah King
Faisal he was a hey food thanks you mean
but did he have that name before the
fighter after the no it was before
because he was always flashy he was
always he had this badass gold chain
dude that it's like it hardly pays I
know a lot of [ __ ] on the
street that can't afford that in here
you have that imprison you have a
religious piece to go with I mean you
can have gold as long as it's a wedding
band you have a watch as long as it's
under 100 bucks but then aren't you a
target for some I know I always wanted
it would be an issue later in the when
you were in the kitchen
mmm and you made a bootleg um seeing
yeah I mean what'd you do that for I
don't get to that part but you say you
were like slowly slowly making a fake
tile out of something you really want to
duplicate a tile yeah he's a pleasure
trying to make you know you're in a fake
one but thank you um to wet it I think
it took me a couple weeks because
because I worked I worked in the main I
drunk art projects here you got all the
time in the block warriors as long as
they don't it's it's the obvious that
they pay attention to it's the little
things they don't they trip on pieces of
metal but when I was there they never
trip on small pieces of metal well this
can be shaved down and attached to this
and now you got a [ __ ] wrench yeah I
mean so I was finding my way with just
little things MacGyver over and I was so
so so the ceiling I worked at this cook
pot my station was the one furthest to
the right so ever you said
I'm sorry too excited to it you saw the
judge each other guy Amanda I better
tell this guy his walls cheap beating
yeah yeah it no cool uh-huh no the free
go right he don't get paid the free
stuff yeah he was the cook he was
technically the head cook even though
they didn't do [ __ ] yeah I mean but but
he would be right there to monitor us so
so part of he would dip out every day
and part of your job is to clean the
pots and clean the floor while the pot
had these hoses that are attached next
time so you could fill him up with for
the oatmeal and stuff like that so I
take the hose turn it on hot water and
Shh
you spray drywall long enough it starts
to yeah warp it starts to come down so I
spit you know the wall painting for that
couple weeks like because I'm your chair
on that I already I already had the plan
if I took enough pieces of cardboard
they had this piece of paper that came
in on the milk crates it was thick like
cardstock similar color so I without the
paint so I made paper mache I used the
cardboard I glued the frick against the
paper to it I said that one of the metal
carts on top to flatten yes I put
magnets in so it was thick yeah so yeah
and then no hives to hook there then
yeah cuz the original plan was to go up
and then break my way into the rooms but
eventually I was able to find my way
through fascinating pieces of metal and
whatnot and I was able to there were
flaws security flaws in there
I'll tell you about one of them [ __ ] it
because I don't ya they're certain I
don't care too much for the people that
are on that yard in that prison right
now some of them so there's
screws right everything's metal
everything's steel everything's concrete
if they put the screws in the wrong
place now I have access to them if I
fasten the right pieces of small metal
that no one trips on because you can't
stab anybody with the piece of metal
this big but you can freakin get a screw
out so they're not as on little things
the smaller things in life you know so I
was able to get they had these big
industrial refrigerators chained to the
wall and the padlock went through the
handle so you couldn't open it and it
was changed to the other wall anyway so
you're screwed well the flaw was they
had the freaking screws on the outside
of the handle and I would take this
drain there's this drain it was a great
you know so food didn't go through it
into the sewer system I take that use it
to take off a nut somewhere else I'd use
that I'll just handle with well it was
the wrench part and then I'd have the
little piece of metal for the
screwdriver and then it was and then I
had ice cream and freakin coffee room
right a few old up into the ceiling yeah
and then you drag it to your room I
would have ways of getting it to this
this was in a it's called this the the
central kitchen so you had to go through
all kinds of security checks to get back
but I was able to get technically
hundreds of pounds of sugar back to the
yard and they just no Bruno Miami guess
Oh watching this same as he logged out
and they were together with him little
kitchen and he stole down bro like a
[ __ ] hefty bag full of spaghetti well
I had regular view now who put up his
sleeve bro he had like a fake leg full
of spaghetti yeah but who gonna serve up
spaghetti saw slash spaghetti where
everybody sleeping you know people do
wanna be spaghetti late at night [ __ ]
meatball I never even had spaghetti you
know they think about in prison waiting
in hospital we had ravioli coming one
time and I and as soon as they know you
know what it came in and then they were
like oh we're gonna not serve this right
now so I stole every single bit of it
and I put it in the ceiling under my
fake drywall and I had like a whole
pallet almost the whole pallet of
ravioli hundreds of pounds of sugar
freaking yeah a little snacks cookies
and stuff and then somebody's little
yeah
yeah like a prison doom prepper the
ingenuity of these guys is always
amazing to me that one
I remember that one we saw with a guy
made a shank out of a like a Starbuck
like a coffee cup lid rolled it no and
then rubbed it on the concrete and
scraped it on the concrete until it
sharpened but like he spent days on this
week's on this see ya
you could also piece of metal there
available and then you sharpen it and
when you're rolling you roll that in as
the tip yeah yeah and it's and they call
it a one-hitter quitter yeah because
it's plastic it's more than likely gonna
break but they tell you melt a piece of
metal into the tip so that way it
pierces the skin and it'll break because
it's plastic but that's why it's called
the one hitter quitter when you're in
prison you say you use heroin one time
you could you continue you did what you
hooked oh yeah I used as soon as I used
here he was outside though no no you
know it was about making the days go by
faster yeah I needed in order to write
yeah telling me that you did it like
like how much did you say you mentioned
that um like you knew when people had
money and when people don't have money
you know when people don't have sprites
or they'll have chips yeah
yeah well the price really goes up the
price really really go up the prices go
up when the yard becomes more dry let's
say so so you have a little the little
totally tiny speck of heroin other end
of a much and you say you were gonna say
that for a month and started for eighty
like I think it was like a couple of
weeks I would do that it was when the
when it's in abundance everyone's trying
maybe more than one person has it and
that's why it's an abundance so people
are trying to outdo each other so some
some they call them papers Bob Ellis is
is the heroin in the plastic right so
you hey let me get up a bit and they
come in different sizes usually so when
it's abundant you'll have a heftier
portion so it was during one of those
times that I got I was able to get my 50
through the handkerchief and the
lightning and then BAM I got my 50s sat
on it because everybody old their
canteen and I knew it's gonna dry you
know
once it's dry I'll be able to get more
bang for my buck because people will
start heroin you know heroines like Tara
was like dude I need it and I'm like all
right I'm like oh how the big homies
told you listen homie with our fool here
get stabbed they are not pain a lot of
well no there's well yeah they told me
don't not pay debts cuz yeah you'll get
stabbed but it's more it's more the
individual that estab you if someone
feels disrespected they'll just call it
a personal issue everything's not some
some gang here you know yeah something
like we were talking about the crazy
ones so the crazy ones you could tell
the crazy ones there's rules in place
there's a hierarchy right if there was
and the crazy ones were like man [ __ ]
your hierarchy and I mean anybody tries
to get sick with me I'm stabbing him you
know so so those are the ones if you owe
them there doesn't have to be any call
any nothing you'll just be there and
they feel disrespect and it's like you
know did you a castle park let's go
castle park middle castle park remain
did he go to castle park school yes he
did full justice park middle and one
year this is a park high school and then
I failed
ninth grade miserably and went to Castle
Park Learning Center so I split to
everybody like the deal you got because
that was your first off fat but your
America two strikes
yeah I was reading the court papers it
was really funny because it contradicts
its a gay people at that so much huh
they said how [ __ ] up because they
could get you for jaywalking and put you
back here for 25 years to life before 24
2014 real clear to put that in right
bill couldn't put it in like on a
federal level but the state governors
are the ones who put it in like gray
Davis
you know Pete Wilson but technically all
of them are to blame since then because
no one's actually made any moves to
change anything
it was people's inmates families inmate
rights groups right and yeah and it's
and it's not to say that some people
don't belong in prison there's people
who I can think of right now that but up
for stealing a pizza for my kid to do
hungry well I'll let you plug him there
was a guy who stole the slice of pizza
the thing that bothered me was that they
were giving people life in prison for
nonviolent crimes and me yes I robbed
banks I belonged in prison but again it
could what hope what do you hope to
achieve by sending someone prison
if it's you want to make them better
it's not happening you know in there if
it's you want revenge because you feel
that disrespected that somebody robbed a
bank over here and you just want them to
suffer for a certain period of time
we'll keep it real and tell them that's
what it is like but don't like [ __ ]
just give them life listen Enfamil
diapers [ __ ] bread they would just
give people life it didn't matter it was
indiscriminate there oh.just
and the judges would say there's nothing
I could do I have to do my job life the
cops would say there's nothing I could
do I have to do my job I'm taking you in
for this petty theft that I know will
get you life the correctional officers
while they're there they'll hold you
there knowing they've probably done a
bump of cocaine in there fun time but
they're gonna keep you there for life
where they get a high off actually cuz
it's a stat for them yeah yeah it's it's
real I don't like how many times people
will say it's my job I was told to do it
by my boss because it's like if your
true interest is justice and yet let's
just say you're a correctional officer
you're really interested in justice
that's why you say you signed up it's
not for the benefits it's not for the
Dental for the vision it's not for the
Union pay vacation pay it's because
you're truly interested in justice if
that was me and I saw somebody spending
25 years no less than 20 a
quarter-century for a bump of cocaine I
would get some of my correctional
officer friends and walked that fool to
the front gate oh well you might go to
jail with [ __ ] that fools doing life
for a bump of cocaine what the [ __ ] is
your problem
oh yeah that's monstrous that's human
right and then they put you in solitary
indiscriminately for nonviolent stuff
you said with all the ICU office rather
the [ __ ] they were doing is you I asked
and they all you guys want to hear it I
do we have time yeah there's there's
there's a prison gang that correctional
officers never want to frickin uh talk
about it's called green wall with green
wall Green was a California prison gang
that consists of nothing but
correctional officers right so and
people have written books about this
there's a book out we're starting the
gladiator fight it's called the green
wall you find it and that was an officer
who was that corker and I believe he saw
everything going on and he reported it
and his life was essentially destroyed
because of it by I mean
I mean what do you do at that point your
your all your coworkers you're out
you're out you're an outcast there's
shit-talking you there is no comfortable
work environment here anymore
yeah I mean so so if that's your career
if that's what you know how to do you're
[ __ ]
and he pretty much quickly found himself
in that situation him and some other
officers testified because they were
killing people not him but the people he
was trying to tell them that they didn't
make him fight
and if if both gladiator fights with
Chintu and enemies were to her death
sometimes they get rival gangs together
that they put them on the same yard or
or release the cells and then and then
just they would know once I released
this cell of this prison gang and this
of this alleged prison gang they're
gonna automatically go after it because
it's you know their policy so they would
do it knowing what was gonna happen and
sometimes when they weren't satisfied
with the fight they'd still shoot you
which there's a video on my site poor
[ __ ] called don't go to prison it has
nothing to do with my book I just put it
there to kind of set the tone for the
kind of stuff you go through in
California prisons yeah there's an
example of a northern Hispanic dude
walking away from a fight after he had
fought with the southern Hispanic dude
he turns around with that little
victorious kind of a chip on his
shoulder walk but he's walking away and
pals shot him in the back and he died
right there and I still remember the the
words from a 60 Minutes article and the
jury acquitted them with smiles on their
faces true [ __ ] dawg
does brutal as [ __ ] yes and then they
expect people to not become brutal other
yeah no there's no I mean do you pretty
much agree that there's zero
rehabilitation of prisoners in the
system there's some rehabilitation or do
you have to want it really be the kind
of person who wants it I'll give you an
example of how the CDC did California
Department of Corrections did
rehabilitation when I was there exactly
when they put the R on the end of CDC
our California Department of Corrections
and Rehabilitation they took away our
[ __ ] high school or GED program or
both I was an optical trying to be an
optician they took that [ __ ] away would
work they took it away Autobody they
took it away they took away anything
that you could do to better yourself the
only the only action you had were
were for drug offenders it's your way
weights too huh they took away waste
before I got there yeah that was like
ninety eight or nine you know I got
there No - oh no it's a prison I got
there no three yeah yeah but it was it's
just a horrible environment honestly but
it's like I understand there's [ __ ]
there I I don't even think all
correctional officers all I don't think
everyone's bad I think every group has
[ __ ] and Android up and yeah and as
long as the the majority of the group is
willing to say like hey we don't accept
this then it would be better but again
if you're a correctional officer and you
speak out you make the [ __ ] mistake
of speaking out against when you're
somebody is doing something bad killing
people planting drugs your life's
[ __ ] ruined so so that's why I say I
don't think all seals are bad because
I'd see the good ones who'd you could
tell it bothered them I'd see them see
[ __ ] going down and you'd see the
uncomfortable look on their face so I
know they're not all bad and I know the
odds they're up against when they do
speak out but I mean there's some pretty
horrendous human rights violations
happen in California as for sure when
you go to prison oh the first thing you
did like what you eat I went to los
taquitos my favorite taco shop would you
get fish damn it was either a California
burrito or carne asada fries would look
like it today Louis taquitos is on third
and main and notch and all thigh but
it's technically authorizing the subsidy
of Chula Vista but it's instead o ty RLS
yes yes that's my click close right here
brother while they listen to everything
about you cheese muscle you said some
dude up there in the oil remain strange
I think that's the guy we don't know the
real name when you got out of prison
whoa did you went back to school hundred
hundred you are we have ability your
self I'm not going back and won't you do
you got a Bitcoin right
yeah I'd invested a Bitcoin yes yes when
I first got out I became an iron worker
I did that for two years I already had a
bad back from running from the cops when
I was a kid how you fell yeah my stupid
ass jumped over a fence
I had always plotted out the freakin get
away from the King part yeah
and I jumped over the freaking fence and
it was a nut it was the other car back
injuries from there it started there and
and then I never got it fixed
and then I went to where is in and then
ironworker was just that was during the
recession there wasn't no taking it easy
back so I got injured moved into
marketing and then I ended up finding
out about cryptocurrency through there
and and slowly started getting into it
over at I think we had actually bought
started buying in 2016 but we didn't
catch on that it was a hustle until like
I'm so growing right even though some
people talk about like it's dead I had
been out of obviously more ATMs every
time I say there's another ATM I see
more and new legacy alibi fluctuates I
saw one on the way on the way hold on a
gas station the truck Derek it's big
yeah but it fluctuates but the like the
risk rates and everything in the price
but it's it's false it's being used that
that's changing all its its own how many
people are accepting it and 2017 was big
2018 [ __ ] suck I lost a lot of money
in that crypto crash but it was all
house money it was all I I pulled out my
entire initial investment in December
2017 just under pressure for my
girlfriend I'd always floss on her and
I'd wake up and be like give me like
five g's you know and she'd be like oh
you're monopoly money
I ain't seen the pain or bills and I'm
like oh [ __ ] you know so I pulled out my
whole initial investment so I so I
didn't take a loss and then I ended but
I ended up having to pull out more for
taxes during the [ __ ] crash like
right in April now I think about it and
and so I sat out of it 2018 and I was
speaking at an event at tinnie in Los
Angeles the booze and book club and I
was uh I was telling somebody like
straight up I'm not in crypto right now
not really you know I'm waiting for it
to find its happy place you know because
I wasn't trying to I was waiting to see
but once it bounced back up and held
okay that's the new support you know I'm
saying so so now we're working our way
up and I got back in and [ __ ] just the
other day I was looking at stocks
they're killing me I was down like 3% in
the morning like by 9:00 10:00 a.m. and
I was looking at like coin seen it going
which is another cryptocurrency
sold that stock that was going down put
it in the light coin called a 6% gain
you know and it's stocks crypto is
freaking sick dude it's it's a nice
legit hustle especially the same thing
you've been doing your whole life though
like this is what I'm saying like he
used those powers for good for good now
oh you know like because you have an
ability not everybody has that though
you talk about it as if it's like the
second nature but you have an ability to
see when something's low and you buy it
and you sell it high or you get it for
free and you sell it from whatever price
and it's all that it's all profit you
know I'm talking about before before in
your life of crime but now you're doing
things for bank robber to wolf of East
lows it's the same I mean it's basically
the stock market does a hustle it's the
same thing when you're buying low and
selling high and you're trying to find
you know how you can make the the
biggest reward I think it is I did go to
Dawson from article as the voice of his
audio yep oh yeah one thing they said in
your book that was cool you gave a lot
of credit to your mom to the rehab
process which a lot of people don't have
any family like you know your mom like
like like your mom spoke spoke oh let
most money like like more Latina mom
like you know like if you say like like
even like if I were to kill it
ten people well he could have killed
thirty only he's a good boy
yeah mom said that about you by mijo
just wrote a note well 20 bud at
sentencing my dad say because you know
my dad went to go visit my brother first
thing he said you better a lot there of
a little puta mom and that [ __ ] bigger
brother laughs he even has a robber you
suck dick yeah you know he didn't hit me
like that he came and visited me
and he was just more like why'd you do
it and again I was so I was so [ __ ] up
in the head as far as dedicated to crime
that uh I was trying to convince my mom
and dad like bail me out and I was
telling my dad cause he was a truck
driver so I'll buy you a truck how's
that gonna buy you chuck I just need to
get out of jail right now who cares if
they look for me you know cuz you know
maybe when I was in the neighborhood
you would hear you might get life in
prison you know but it was more like I
really hope that doesn't happen but it
was always a possibility
you know because you see they give
people life in prison for how I'm [ __ ]
so it's like okay that can happen or you
might die I mean like people in might
yeah it's it's it's it's just a
screwed-up situation screwed up when you
grow up being surrounded by nothing but
people who maybe they're trying to help
you but it's just in the wrong way like
I used to try and help people getting
out of prison when I would sell drugs at
one point and my way of helping the
homies getting out of prison was here's
an ounce of meth you know I mean break
that [ __ ] down into 20s and you're
[ __ ] lookin good you know and that was
my way of help I genuinely believe I'm
helping you now I'm leading to his
addiction and food probably got crack
got five [ __ ] years and you know what
I mean but that's your yeah that's my
way of helping so when everyone around
you is gonna hear the holy war this is
what it is you know this is the life and
and anything else is lame you know I'm
seeing I'm hoping to come out of prison
or come on whatever they came out of
somebody always give everything new new
paths new Air Force Ones
everything you need it even I'm dope to
get started but it's up to you at the
end of the weekend that's all it is it's
not only you're gonna pay them on your
back or be an outcast that's it and most
of the kind of able to be outcasts on
yeah I don't fool them inside out you
see homie that would come on a present
and they come out yoke as hell like the
buff I mean a three way down the line
it's done with another more Souls prison
yeah the prison clothes are loose and
they go back to prison in the same
[ __ ] clothes mm-hmm another clean
where can people find your book yet oh
man it's online up on game from robbing
banks stacking Bitcoin it's on amaz
you could get on my site up on gamebook
comm audible.com just keyword search up
on game how about uh how about and it's
an auto basel yeah yeah people coaches
like this book on audible it's it's a
easy read after every chapter you hear a
little talk
you've been reading it right I read all
of it yeah are you doing the book
signings be able to go to or speaking
event I know who's in book club boozing
book club in Los Angeles with the people
people drink beer and your book they
drink Carola
cocktails is what they served there and
then Mike Dawson actually reads a
chapter two from the book and then the
audience is allowed to do a Q&A with the
author ask him anything you want
hello caller from San Diego Adam Carolla
know right Valley yeah you know Valley
Jimmy Jimmy Kimmel from San Diego Vegas
but they're friends they're like the
friend all the guy from San Diego the
one that has a show in the producer of
that show the voice I don't know no
Carson Carson Daly only because they all
met in Las Vegas when there were DJ's
Jimmy Carson Daly that's cool back story
what's up fool would you answer bro no
nothing well they can find your events
at your website sorry yes any any any
readings go to um I don't have I have
another podcast I'm doing later today
but I don't have a podcast we're at it's
in Burbank to a little bit it's it's the
first one they're having that's Josh and
Darius I don't know what they're calling
it but I'm going by to help them out oh
yeah and you know tell some stories no
but yeah as far as I go
just or Twitter or it's all up a game up
on game book yeah Twitter up on game
book Instagram up on game book yeah fine
well thank you ma'am you know oh thank
you for having me you let the podrace
the Padres what's off for this week I'm
gonna be in New York City I shouldn't
let this week next week June 22 or 2300
lines out Broadway
Atlanta Georgia punchline to June 28th
to 30th Houston Texas Houston improv
July 5th through 7th Chicago Illinois
the big theater director team Tucson
Sawadee Torres gonna chase with diamond
casino July 26th I'll do a Spanish show
at the comedy palace also next week June
11 are gonna be he'll be willows cheese
tears at the Riverside Civic Center life
Art Center life art centers will be
always Spanish [ __ ] laude
I might have birthday cake on Monday
we're gonna go alive but be able to go
live at 8 p.m. and then that is when
they were gonna go live at 8 p.m. on
youtube.com slash ATC and that's a sure
thing Rene Garcia's because he'll be
here with a Google glass - and then
Wednesday we're gonna have Earl Skakel
but that may not what's up fool up on
game up on game Richard Stanley read all
the chapters